this is a very cool stone cutting a
heart shape is difficult to then set an
emerald in bezel with lots of little
diamonds around is dangerous on the
jeweler's bench so this ring forget how
cool-looking it is is a really delicate
piece that was handled with extreme care
made by a very high-end craftsman for
sure
it's not a lot of people who can wear
this ring as well as Tyler the Creator
[Music]
I'm David Ali I'm a 25-year master
jeweler in diamonds here today men are
really taking risks and having a lot of
fun with their jewelry something we
haven't seen in quite a while
it's great for us because we can have
fun too guys are getting more and more
comfortable being bold with their
jewelry also not just wearing things
here they're wearing diamonds wearing
other precious stones a lot of these
stereotypes that jewelry should be for
women is just completely washing away
today we're going to be talking about
men's rings and trends you see lately
you'll tend to see guys wearing multiple
thin them she's really cool that's to
build their own style don't look so
Timothy shallow mate he's got great
style he's keeping it super minimal here
it's easier than a white t-shirt pair of
jeans and really simple rings I love
that look very less is more
very cool you can do whatever you want
that's right wear them all the time and
they go with anything and everything so
you can definitely keep them on as far
as your style goes and your outfits and
what you're doing from jeans and a
t-shirt to a black-tie event
dapper Montgomery a Renaissance man he's
an actor he's a poet and he's becoming a
style icon this guy it's amazing what
he's doing I love this set of rings he
has on his pinky oh man Billy Porter
he's amazing Billy Porter is wearing
what looks to be like platinum ring on
one hand with pave diamonds on his other
hand that ring with the little ball of
pave-set diamonds looks like platinum as
well the other three rings look like a
mix of yellow gold and either platinum
or white gold everything is very minimal
and very clean it just balances out with
what he's doing
perfectly pave itself comes from the
French word for pavement the pave
setting is a diamond set into the
surface of the material you carefully
drill the holes for them and you will
burnish down little beads to hold them
in place on creates a very smooth
surface of stones can be either one row
or like in Billy Porter's ring on his
left and here in designs or in the ring
on his right hand you have this ball
this surface so you've got little beads
of metal holding between each of the
round diamond very cool way to bring
surface texture and design elements to
piece it's not to be confused with
channel setting channel setting is where
metal is hammered over the edges of the
stones sizing is a concern especially
when a man is wearing his first ring
that happens either with class ring or
more commonly with a wedding band most
guys will feel like this fits but it
doesn't this will fall off there's no
doubt about it ring is supposed to come
off at the bit of a struggle like that
your body will get used to it very
quickly so you know a lot of guys will
put on a ring and feel like it's tight
and choking them we tell them settle
down for a minute wear it your body will
get used to it really quickly this I
absolutely love what's going on today
with men wearing diamonds boldly is just
fantastic and I really hope it stays and
exists as a mainstay of jewelry why
can't men wear time you look back
historically within the Maharajah's this
was the first culture that actually
started cutting down these men were
covered in precious stones and diamonds
it was a thing that represented power
and boldness so that guys are doing it
today
is super exciting they're not afraid
anymore and like you see on Travis Scott
here he's wearing two super cool rings
the ring on the left is an eternity
better this was something you would
traditionally see as a woman's wedding
band but what he's wearing it here it's
his ring it's a guy's ring it speaks so
much of his style and his boldness and
then he pairs that next to this amazing
ring that has yellow diamonds surrounded
by a little frame of white pave diamonds
so what Travis Scott is wearing or not
only three different styles of rings but
there are three different cuts of
diamonds on the thin band on his middle
ring you have your modern round
brilliant cut done on the ring on the
left cushion cut diamond set in an
eternity band so these have a shared
prong between each stone and each stone
is that cushion shape is a square
diamond with soft sides and soft corners
and then on the ring on the right on his
pinky yellow diamonds which are a
radiant cut radiant cut is a square or a
rectangle with cut corners like the
emerald cut diamond but these are highly
faceted they have tremendous sparkle and
light play Jaden Smith this guy brings
it he's wearing five six seven eight ten
rings almost on his two hands I think
that's amazing and all different and
they're all alive and they're all just
style each and every one by themselves
and then you put them together and this
guy just rings fire he's amazing what
you're seeing here on Tyler the Creator
and ASAP ferg is a great trend that men
are really taking to and getting more
and more comfortable with which is color
what you see on Tyler the Creator are
colored diamonds these are blue diamonds
they're color enhanced blue diamonds say
that it's not a bad thing it's just
think these diamonds when they were
caught had a natural brown color to them
from hydrogen contamination in the stone
and when they're heated radiation this
certainly frequency that color turns to
blue it just tweaks the molecular
structure of the stones and the light
twists around and is inhibited and that
blue comes back out instead of the other
colors and they have this neon e blue
color to them which is not what you see
in a naturally occurring blue diamonds
and this is really this is a style
choice to see these things in this
vibrant color on ASAP ferg you're seeing
this multicolor ring with little pave
diamonds around and what that is those
are all sapphires no sapphires occur in
ten different colors if you will in
shades of these different colors so you
get pinks and purples and yellow and
orange and green and this amazing array
of color on his hand it's just super
cool and he wears it really well
let's talk about Brad Pitt first of all
anything this guy does just becomes cool
whether it was before or not Brad Pitt
is wearing his honey bee on his ring
he's got two of them one in white and
yellow one in yellow honey bee is a
symbol of abundance and the Sun and
power and longevity just cool to see him
wearing that the signet ring has been
around for millennia
this is something that royalty and
powerful men wore to let you know who
they were
you know the signet ring was a marker
for a group you were what family you
were in what your beliefs were and it
was used also as a physical object to
stamp a seal on important documents you
have sometimes family crests on there
you have animals on there that stand for
certain things you have initials on
there love me some Johnny Depp ring is
wearing is so cool with a blue stone in
there that's called lapis lazuli lapis
is very serious stone in history it
carries a lot of energy here it's used
as this signet ring it was also used by
Renaissance painters to make which blue
color them crush it off and turn it into
a powder used it for their blue paint I
think it's a bird carved into the lapis
itself which is another power symbol
written on the side of the Ring is the
word captain I can only think that this
is for Captain Jack Sparrow and that's
been a big big part of Johnny Depp's
life for a very long time and he wears
it really proud
[Music]
Green is having a moment you see a lot
of emeralds especially that guys today
that ring on Big Sean is really
old-school I'm like your grandma's right
right or your great-grandmother's ring
or really an old King's ring you have
this big bold stone in the center and
you have big diamonds all around making
this a very royal-looking ring and he
wears it beautiful emerald can be very
expensive and holds an interesting stone
there are often misconceptions about how
a stone is supposed to look like an
emerald is supposed to be this deep
green but emeralds can be super pale
they can be a brighter green neon green
it can be so deep that they almost look
black in some light so they sharpen all
sorts of different tone Tyler the
Creator is wearing super cool emerald
here you don't see a lot of heart shape
anything this is a very cool stone I'm
gonna ring like this with this level of
craftsmanship and manufacture you know
is a five figure ring it could be more
if this is a super high-end really clean
rich in color like it is emerald pearls
are something we have not seen on men in
modern history at all if you look back
to the Renaissance in before Victorian
time men always wore pearls in fact more
often would you see a pearl and pearl
jewelry on men than you would Unwin whoo
ASAP rocky look at this pink tuxedo
pearl rings pearl necklace he's just
fantastic this guy and I love these
wearing two different style pearl ring
and one has diamonds around it it's a
slightly different color pearl than the
other one it's a bit more of a golden
pearl peachy pinkish color pearl and the
one and his other finger which has very
little embellishment around it or little
diamonds on the prongs is a super white
pearl just works on the pink he's
wearing the white that he's wearing he
rocks all of it there are a few
different kinds of pearls you have
freshwater pearls seed pearls bobby
pearls baroque pearls South Sea pearls
these are serious serious you can have
South Sea pearls that could take in 20
years to collect
a perfect group of the same size blemish
free pearls that could be in the
millions of dollars easily so these
golden tones
these yellows Browns you have citrine
you have carnelian you have sapphire
there's a lot of things that show up in
yellow topaz Timothy sha'lame is wearing
a really cool ring here this is an agate
stone which is Emily regarded as a
lesser value stone most agate shows up a
little bit more like a rock this is a
really gem piece of agate and it's it's
carved beautifully look how he's wearing
it with this little bit of yellow of
golden tones in his outfit just balance
out great with that ring he's with this
kid's got fantastic style you can see it
right here
Nick Jonas also wearing a great ring
this is a a little bit of a signet style
ring as well and he's got in this ring
it's carnelian carnelian relatively soft
material it's easy to carve so you have
to be a little bit careful when wearing
something like this if you bang it can
break but it's set here in a bezel which
does protect the edges of the stones
really nicely future looks great here
also he's blonde here he's got this big
yellow citrine with yellow diamonds and
yellow gold and all his yellow gold
chains is amber glasses he's put
together a whole look here this massive
stone I mean that's probably 20 carats
that stone by another 10 character with
the diamonds around this whole ring it's
bold and it kind of stands out with
everything that he's doing as the first
thing you see most diamonds get their
collar from a mineral contaminated
yellow diamond will be very rich with
nitrogen carbon hydrogen nitrogen these
are the most abundant things in nature
so when a diamond was being compressed
near the core of the earth lots of other
material got trapped into the molecular
structure of the stone it's when the
light enters into the diamond it
inhibits the light play on the molecule
that is traveling through
the Royal old-school aspect of the pinky
ring is one thing where they were worn
by kings and Pope's and royalty at large
and it was something that people would
recognize as their place in society in
the 70s and the 80s especially eighties
they had big old rings that commanded
respect we've all seen in the movies
kissing of the Dawn's hand with the ring
it's something that went out of style
for a while and I think people were
afraid to wear a pinky ring because it
spoke too much of trying to be that
person but today it's come back as such
a style as such a an iconic item and
there's no way to wear a pinky ring the
wrong way whatever you feel like putting
on your hand there from a thin band to a
big diamond to a motif to a signet ring
it all works so here is next level pinky
ring
you've got future you've got gucci mane
you've got ASAP ferg wearing monsters i
mean they're wearing huge diamonds on
their hands and this is the ultimate
statement in a pinkie ring between the
three of them here you have 50 or more
character at the diamonds it's quite
amazing they wear these things not just
proudly but they're fun and they're
exciting and they're cool and they're
different from what we've seen certainly
historically as the pinky ring and
they're bringing it to the forefront of
fashion today and making it a not just a
trend again I think this is one of the
things that's happening today where guys
are so comfortable bringing new styles
to the forefront of fashion that they're
going to stick these are going to be
things that we continue to see for years
Gucci's wearing rings that I mean the
two rings together are over a million
dollars there's no question about it
massive very high-quality diamonds
what does that ring 20 carats the one on
his right hand I think a little smaller
the one on his left you know all of
these rings are are fifty to a hundred
or more thousand dollars something of
this size and this amount of diamond and
labor going on in it so to keep hook to
get away with this look you you've got
to spend some money on it for sure
I continue to see more and more fresh
ideas coming out with the bold style
that's happening with people today and
we've seen it on the runway in clothing
for years and this is happening with
jewelry is a natural progression there's
a lot of great things for the people who
don't have a million dollars to drop on
a pinkie ring you don't have to wear a
big diamond to have a bold ring you
could wear a less expensive
semi-precious stone you can wear a pave
ring with lots of little diamonds on it
you can wear a ring that has no stone
it's really about making your statement